here's
here's what people have to realize
what's going on today
we've been publicly supportive of
both trump we've been publicly
supportive of biden
in areas we've been publicly supportive
and
not supportive of trump or biden we have
voted
we voted for left we voted for right i
have voted for both sides politically
i think when you forget like i run a
company with people on the left people
on the right people in the middle people
christian muslim it doesn't matter we
have people from all walks of life in
the company
when you no longer want to hear what the
other side has to say
you have a big problem okay you have a
big problem by the way
i i as as much as we talk about these
twitter suspensions that we're talking
about
if it becomes being handed out left and
right freely that's you're playing with
fire right then when you say
like the james o'keefe thing where uh
they took the guy down
project but then you saw what he said if
you do this you get your account back
and what did he say
i'm back is it fair to say that here's
project veritas he shows
videos of jack dorsey he throws jack
dorsey under the bus
and dorsey still lets him stay on i
don't know about that i don't know if
you guys don't know what i'm saying or
not
so he puts videos of dorsey and puts
videos of
executives of twitter talking about
their political agenda
and twitter still keeps them on why
did that happen right that just happened
what are you doing keeping them on
right so you understand what i'm going
with absolutely they're not going to
just boot you for what i'm trying to say
is if you keep there
there is a very annoying aspect of what
project
he is very annoying to people on the
left in silicon valley
very annoying because he's calling all
them out he pokes the bear and you let
that guy stay on
yeah yeah so so there has to be how do
you think they let him stay on well
because he hasn't maybe broken the
guidelines yet
and they've given him opportunities to
come back to delete this tweet or do
this and do that in the great
they're i respect that so what i'm
saying to you is i also respect that so
the challenge happens when the far right
folks
don't have the ability to reason and the
challenge happens when far left folks
don't have the ability to reason if you
can't
do that just go to a place where
everybody agrees with you because this
ain't the place
ain't the place that you can agree with
everything we talk about this is not the
podcast for you
go to a completely different place than
here no back to your
point of what we're doing here how tom
was a little further right i was for the
left we're bringing it together you have
things that
you know you you're more left on more
right on capitalism
uh social issues you know something that
i think
as a country we need to do better than
is blanket statements if you voted for
trump then you're a racist
yep i'll never speak to you again if you
voted for biden then you're clearly a
communist
you're a socialist i know what you are
you're antifa
if you voted for trump clearly uh you
hate uh
anyone that's different like dude relax
trump's a nazi
dude what are you talking about it's so
freaking extreme to the ability to
reason
the ability to have a conversation that
say tom i disagree with this this
this but i hear you on this this and
this can we agree that
well pat you said like everything that
you said is exactly the reason why we do
this podcast
we want to have different voices coming
together and finding
some commonality here and that's a
problem in this country is the
the the complete just well you this are
you this
it's it's it's messed up and i think
that that needs to be
yeah look i'm here because of the idea
of america which is what freedom of
speech
pro second amendment pro just look at my
safe
you you can go down the list of stuff
that america offers you right free
enterprise all
in freedom of assembly all day long for
you go down freedom of
religion what do you want to be go be at
it you want to be christian jehovah
seventh day
go go for it all of those things is why
many immigrants like myself are in
america happily
in america i'm gonna do my part to fight
to make sure those things
stay in place having said that you are
absolutely naive if you don't realize
how much influence social media silicon
valley have
and by the way to everybody on the right
that complains about it
do something about it parlor's not the
way to go by the way
partly you ain't look there's a saying
that in business you say bring him in
first
baptize him later okay too many people
want to baptize
before they bring him into the church i
don't know if that saying makes sense
let me explain to what i mean by this so
for example
um i go to a bike shop the other day
you know i want to buy something i'm
going to spend a few hundred dollars i
mean less than thousand dollars
i said put your mask on i said i forgot
my mask at the house i said you guys got
one of these blue masks no we don't have
the mask go get it yourself
wow so i'm like this guy so i'm like
okay so i go back
i get the mask i come back and i'm
thinking to myself the mask i want on
amazon you can buy 149
449 you can buy 2 000 masks
ends up becoming 7 cents a pop for a
mask okay
your seven cents just cost you five
hundred dollars
right that 500 profit margin to you is
typically 40
on the 40 you can end up keeping you
know 20
say 100 you would have netted because
you got to pay the employee sales
rent all this stuff you just seven cents
a hundred you tell me which bitcoin
which stock
that you spend seven cents gives you
a hundred dollars not one investment is
going to give you that right
okay so let's just say
you are anti-mask let's just say you say
this is stupid
nobody should be wearing a mask you know
we're such followers and sheeps
okay say you believe that fine
is it worth you not having a box of
masks there
to allow a liberal who wears four masks
to come in that spends a thousand
do you care politically where a person
is if they're gonna do business with you
no that's called capitalism if you only
want to do business
with republicans that's your business
model fine if you only want to do
business with democrats fine
when aoc put her sweater up said what
tax the rich for 68 bucks kevin already
bought it
and kevin o'leary said look even an a
even a socialist eventually becomes a
capitalist
he did a video and says hey aoc why
don't you contact me i'd love for us to
start a business together i'd invested
these sweaters here let's do something
together as a capitalist
he's taking a shot at her but even an
aoc understands
she's willing to sell that sweater to a
republican she's willing to sell that
sweater to anybody right
okay so invite him first baptize him
later right
invite him to the church baptize them
later
sometimes if your platform is only
one side you're not gonna baptize and
convert people
the name of the game is converting the
name of the game
isn't talking to people who already
agree with you
the name of the game is to convert
people any platform or leader that
converts that's a leader
any leader or platform that's just
talking to the same audience that's
agreeing with you you ain't making any
kind of a change by the way
everybody agrees with you there's no
influence being made and honestly to be
honest and take this even to a different
level
you're actually copping out you're
actually
weaker i don't this makes sense so okay
so so for the christian community
where did he go to want to baptize
people you read the bible where did he
go where did jesus go did he go to
islam did he go to where everybody
agreed with them
you go to the best salesperson where do
you go do you just go and talk to your
customers i went to an office one time
you know these companies that they do
the trashes they recycle what do you
call those companies
something landfills or something what is
the name of it there's a name of it no
it's actually a big it's a multi-billion
dollar company
that recycles papers we have them
ourselves i don't know the company we
have a big contract with them
anyways so i go into the office and
the the vice president of that office
invites me in and i'm speaking to their
guys can you talk my sales because i'm
trying to figure out a way to improve my
sales guys i said great
so i set up and i said okay um out of
your
calls at you how many calls you make per
week they give me the number i said how
many dinner to existing customers how
many are to new customers oh 95 percent
okay 95 to new customers right oh no no
no
no 95 to existing customers i said
there's your problem so we don't even
need to go anywhere else
speech over so how long you've been in
sales 20 years how long you been here 15
years
how long have you guys been flat in this
office about nine years we don't call it
flat we just say
call it consistent i said i'm sorry i
call it flat in the world of business
you either groan or you're down you guys
are dying just everybody knows this
i said how come you guys don't knock on
doors or go talk to businesses that are
not customers of yours
you ain't growing your business you're
just rehashing the same exact customers
and by the way you're eventually going
to lose customers to somebody else
that's not bring them in
baptize them later i'm in the game of
converting
i'm in the game of getting people who
are not believers of business to say
babe maybe we start a business part-time
i'm in the game of getting people to say
you know like yesterday gray came in
here he said the most interesting thing
the guy that we wrote a book together
with
phenomenal thing he got emotional he's
here yesterday he had he we had a very
special moment he says you know what's
crazy pat
i said what's that he says you know what
was the toughest thing about writing
this book with you because he's my
writer he wrote the book we're not
co-authors he's a writer he wrote so
rather than getting a ghostwriter and
said i wrote this book i don't write
this book we wrote it together but he's
my writer right okay
he says because he saw me intentionally
i said before you write this book you
have to see me at the best of my worst
he says what do you mean i want you to
be in my board meetings and see how i
react
i said i want you to see me in sales
meetings and see how i react he says you
can go in the most exclusive meetings
that nobody else has invited
then you can write the book so he saw me
everywhere he saw him he was with me
with kobe with
bush with back end i'm upset things are
not working out i'm in my suite
that's caesar he's everywhere seeing me
at my
best worst ticked off losing it this
didn't work out just lost couple hundred
he's seen everything
right i said now you can write the book
then we write the book together
you know what he said yesterday was so
moving he says pat you know
i'm the professor i'm the guy that's the
consultant
i'm the one that tells people what to do
he says the hardest thing about writing
the book with you
is you forced me to get in the arena he
said i have not been in the arena for 15
20 years
see that to me is winning because i
converted someone to get into the arena
you win when you convert you don't win
when you're talking to the same people
that say uh-huh and did you see
these guys don't care about us you are
not winning
you win when you convert the left won
because they converted
the right loss because they stop
converting and paying attention to the
people who are younger in social media
you lost that's a strategic loss
what did i vote for you think i'm voting
to raise the taxes
no you think i'm voting for i got an
email yesterday for my friends at
goldman sachs there's a very high
likelihood taxes are going up
i've known this you think we voted for
that we want to put the money back into
the business
no we don't vote for raising taxes we
don't vote for
you know hey let's go pay off everyone's
college we don't vote for that stuff
we vote for free enterprise free market
i don't care who the person is
i don't even want to see the face of
trump on biden give me your policies
i'll tell you who i'm voting for
that's who we vote for then it didn't
work out why didn't it work out
it's strategy so there there is a very
very big misconception and a mindset
by the way christians i want to spoke to
a group of pastors in newport beach
and they invited me can you come and
talk to these pastors i said hey
uh why has donations have gone down
not to your church to christian churches
why are christian churches so empty
why why why is it well it's because the
new generation you know they just don't
want to tie it and they don't understand
that the bible
ah no no no no don't get technical don't
blame the new generation because you
walked
up two hills when you're going to school
and it was snow you know all those
stories that we always hear about
why has it well you know all these
things i heard i said can i tell you the
truth what
i said mormon church is killing it
same generation why is the mormonism
killing it i said you ever gone to
mormon's
uh uh youtube channel yeah have you can
you go to lds's youtube channel
no i pulled it out i said let's go no no
no i said listen i'm not telling you go
become a mormon
i'm telling you during the same time
that you're losing members and donators
mormonism's killing it how many
subscribers does lds have just type in
lds and go to channel
1.63 million subscribers a
a religion lds has 1.63
you you go look at the lds church why
have they they have a system
they're young look at their videos go go
to
uh fill sort by go to sort by on the top
right look at it
14 million view okay 12 million view
nine and a half million i'm a child of
god i'm
okay how come christians are in churches
are not growing up
i go to a church in dallas i'm not gonna
say the name i go to a church in dallas
it's a big church fits 5 000 people
600 people are there 75 year old pastor
is preaching it's time to be a mentor
let a young guy come in and do it you
preach maybe once a month yeah
but no still have to have control so
again but you're not converting mr
pastor
but i know everything about the bible
enough it doesn't matter the idea of
christianity is to go disciple
it's the cost of disciples when you
become a christian the first book they
ask you to read is the cause of
discipleship depending on what church
you go to
cost of discipleship is what what
happens to be a disciple
because the whole idea of becoming a
christian is to what to convert
the idea of business is what to convert
to somebody to say i believe in you
steve jobs
let's go change the world i believe in
you elon musk let's go change the world
don't make don't ask any question just
get on the damn what the jet the plane
don't question anything let's just go
right okay people have forgotten
that politics business religion
family anything you look at is all about
converting
and whoever's converting is winning and
whoever just wants to talk to people
that agree with them
you are not losing you're gonna get your
ass handed to you in ways you've never
been handed to before
and the separation of the the competitor
is not going to be small
it's going to be a wide wide distance
separation between you and your
competitors
and it's not going to be pretty that's
what's going on today with politics yeah
very interesting so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you